catalina lopez bonjour oui bonjour à lui
désire partager
alors vous dirigez le réseau canadien de
génomique
c'est bien sûr un tel restaurant indien
de génériques de kovy d' allah de la
copie de 19
super alors nous allons essentiellement
parlé de lakovic 19 parce que ces
derniers jours il ya de nouveau
vocabulaire sur la place publique on
parle d'un séquençage de trèbes l'âge
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire un peu
ce que ça signifie cris blessé quand
c'est quoi ce vocabulaire là oui ça fait
jeune comique mais j'avais jamais autant
entendu parler de génomique de
séquençage dans les médias et les fêtes
comme vous l'avez dit on commence à
parler beaucoup oui pour expliquer les
pâtons simple le virus le virus qui
produit la comédie 9
c'est un virus des arn qui a trente
mille lettres
trente mille paires de bases et quand on
sait qu'un en fait c'est qu'on regarde
et on fait la lecture de cette trente
mille lettres de code génétique du virus
quand on fait un test on dit simplement
oui non le virus se pressent au présent
mais quand on fait les séquençages c'est
qu'on s'est la lecture complète de code
génétique de virus et sa part ça vous
prend à peu près combien de temps pour
faire ce séquençage là pour pouvoir lire
tous ces signaux là j'imagine que c'est
beaucoup de travail
oui c'est beaucoup de travail et
beaucoup de technologies mais
heureusement pour nous le canada ça fait
20 ans qu'on investit en génomique 20
ans qu'on investit dans les technologies
de séquençage et ça fait qu' on est en
fait capable de lire la totalité des
laden
assez rapidement mais il ya quand même
beaucoup d'autres choses
autour il est à trouver les échantillons
préparer les échantillons faire
l'analyse de données fois qu'on a fait
la lecture lecture en soit les steak
enfin ça peut prendre deux trois jours
mais après tout le processus ça peut
prendre parfois une semaine deux
semaines ça dépend et parfois un peu
plus long pour trouver les échantillons
donc c'est quand même un processus qui
est pas seulement la lecture ou les
séquençages mais tous qui a oscillé
logistique autour
je comprends que le canada a quand même
une certaine expertise dans ce dossier
là mais on a quand même commencé qui
concerne la copie de 19 ans on est un
peu à la traîne par rapport aux pays
comme le royaume-uni les etats-unis
est ce que vous allez noué un
partenariat avec ces pays là pour
pouvoir avancer un peu plus vite
oui on a déjà développé des partenariats
avec angleterre ce e qui sont vraiment
plus à l'avancé un terme d'un séquençage
juste pour vous donner les chiffres nous
le canada on est en train de séquencer
autour de 5% de la totalité des cas
positive dans les pays
donc on prend 1 5% de tous le positiver
on lui la totalité de l'adn l'angleterre
de son côté fait autour de 8 à 10%
mais les états unis ils sont ils font
actuellement uniquement 1% et parfois
avant je pense que même moins d 1 pour
ça donc c'est vraiment un tout petit
pourcentage qui font les états unis nous
on c'est pour ça qu'on regarde plutôt à
notre partenariat avec les angles à
faire
on collabore ont beaucoup avec eux et on
travaille de très près avec nos
collègues de l'initiative qui s'appelle
co uk
l initiative séquençage du virus en
angleterre j'imagine que cette démarche
préalable est très très utile très
importante dans la lutte contre cette
pandémie qui fait des ravages dans le
monde
absolument absolument bad je pense que
on se trouve quand même dans une bonne
position par rapport à plein d'autres
pays dans le monde qui n'ont pas les
capacités ont pas l'expertisé on parle
et d'équipements pour faire les
séquençages donc nous surtout
actuellement quand on commence à parler
de ces nouvelles variantes du virus et
que évidemment la génomique et le
séquençage on prend une place beaucoup
plus important pour nous aider à
comprendre où se trouvent ses variantes
comment la distribution de ces variants
de ces investissements qu'on a fait avec
génome canada génome québec au québec et
partout au canada
vraiment une porte fruit pour qu'on soit
vraiment bien préparé pour faire
visualise actuellement et justement
j'imagine c'est un travail qui est très
complexe
parce que quand on entend des
spécialistes en parler c'est comme si
les variants n'ont pas de limites
jusqu'où il compte et vous allez dans le
travail de séquençage
oui en fait écouter ça fait un an qu'on
a plus d'un an qu'on a annoncé pandémie
ça fait le premier on a commencé le
réseau de génomique de co vide en bois
d'avril et on a commencé à faire de ces
quand on avait détecté quelques
variantes parce que les vieux c'est
toujours en train de décharger de faire
des mutations
mais c'est seulement à partir des
chambres qu'on a commencé à avancer
d'arrière qu'on appelle préoccupante aux
bâtisseurs comme on dit en anglais donc
ses variantes qui ont plus de
transmissibilité ou que peut-être vont
pas répondre au vaccin ou aux
traitements et depuis qu'on a parlé de
la première variante qui est la variable
qui a été découverte en angleterre on a
commencé à parler de ça sérieusement au
niveau international au mois de décembre
est lentement la variante découverte en
angleterre aussi au brésil en afrique du
sud la finition bouger rien hexaquine du
sud au nigeria
on a une nouvelle variante
nigeria et et on a aussi bariant ton
décalé fournis dans ce cas là en fait ce
qui montre ce que le virus
il commença il ya commencé à apprendre
un peu comment comment échapper notre
système immunitaire au niveau de
problèmes de la population
quand même aussi intéressant au niveau à
biologique mais tout à fait on développe
des vaccins mais le virus est très rusé
il paraît très très rusé et développe
aussi ses propres stratégies de
résistance
alors j'imagine que votre avis oui
j'imagine que votre travail est très
très minutieux d'où l'importance d'une
stratégie vous parlez à votre niveau
d'une stratégie intégrée
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner les
grands axes de cette stratégie
actuellement oui donc nous on a on a
comme je disais on fait 5 % de cas on
essaye petit à petit d'augmenter chaque
petit appétit non j'irai rapidement donc
moi fonçant vers 1 10 % des échantillons
mais on fait aussi ce qu'on appelle une
stratégie d'échantillonnage c'est pas
simplement séquencé pour ces cancers ou
à laisser casser tout ce qu'on voit mais
on a développé un mois de décembre avec
les laboratoires pour vent sur toute une
stratégie pour prioriser les
échantillons qui sont potentiellement
suspicieux d'avoir des mutations et
d'avoir des mutations qui vont qui sont
les mutations préoccupante au les
variantes près tu parles
donc on a développé tous et de stratégie
avec le laboratoire national de
microbiologie avec les différents
partenaires du réseau de génomique du
coc vide au canada et ça me faisait
vraiment c'est pas une question
uniquement d'un nombre de chiffres 5% à
10%
mais c'est une question de stratégie et
c'est là où on fait l'enfance avec un
coup de jeune et bien voilà c'était
catalina lopez correa qui est donc la
directrice générale du réseau canadien
de génomique
vous faites donc ce travail de
séquençage et de criblage en partenariat
avec santé canada et le la
rappaz de microbiologie du canada je
remercie infiniment d'avoir pris de
temps à vous avant un grand merci au
revoir